darüber folgen dieser infektion
diskutiert und in der folge haben ja
auch alle länder die schulen und kitas
bundesweit geschlossen oder werden es in
kürze tun
heute haben wir gemeinsam mit den
ländern weitere leitlinien für das
allgemeine verhalten beschlossen
es leitet uns dabei das was uns immer
wieder von der wissenschaft gesagt wird
nämlich dass die wirksamste maßnahme um
diese infektion zu verringern das
erhöhen der distanz ist des abstandes
ist also das verringern von sozialen
kontakten und wir wollen natürlich
versuchen die wirtschaftlichen prozesse
so weit wie möglich ohne auswirkungen
geht es nicht das wissen wir bereits
erhalten wir wollen garantieren dass die
medizinische versorgung gewährleistet
werden kann dass die energieversorgung
gewährleistet ist dass die ernährung der
bevölkerung gewährleistet ist und dass
auch ein großer teil der
dienstleistungen in anspruch genommen
werden kann und dennoch brauchen wir
einschneidende maßnahmen um das
infektionsgeschehen wie so oft schon
gesagt zu verlangsamen
das sind maßnahmen dieses in unserem
lande so noch nicht gegeben hat die
natürlich einschneidend sind aber sie
sind im augenblick notwendig um die zahl
der kontakte zu reduzieren und damit
auch die zahl der erkrankungen und damit
auch die zahl der schweren erkrankungen
zu reduzieren uns unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überfordern
das ist etwas außerordentliches was wir
heute gemeinsam besprochen haben mit den
bundesländern
die maßnahmen sind auch zum großen teil
und überwiegend durch die bundesländer
umzusetzen sie werden das in kürze tun
wenn sie es nicht zum teil schon getan
haben
aber uns war allen sehr wichtig dass wir
ein im großen ganzen einheitliches
handeln in deutschland haben und weil
diese maßnahmen so besonders sind möchte
ich sie auch hier heute einmal im detail
vortragen
ich beginne mit dem was ausdrücklich
nicht geschlossen wird
das ist mir sehr wichtig ausdrücklich
nicht geschlossen
wird der einzelhandel für lebensmittel
wochenmärkte abhol und lieferdienste
getränkemärkte apotheken sanitätshäuser
drogerien tankstellen banken und
sparkassen poststellen druck friseure
reinigungen waschsalons der
zeitungsverkauf bau und garten und
tierbedarf märkte und der großhandel
vielmehr sollten für diese von mir jetzt
genannten bereiche sogar überlegt werden
ob er die sonntags verkaufsverbote bis
auf weiteres grundsätzlich aussetzen und
eine öffnung dieser genannten
einrichtungen erfolgt natürlich unter
auflagen zur hygiene zur steuerung des
zutritts und zur vermeidung von
warteschlangen dienstleister und
handwerker können ihrer tätigkeit weiter
nachgehen und alle einrichtungen des
gesundheitswesens bleiben unter
beachtung der gestiegenen hygienischen
anforderungen geöffnet das sind die
dinge die wichtig sind dass sie weiter
von den bürgerinnen und bürgern den
anspruch genommen werden könnten
zweitens für den publikumsverkehr zu
schließen sind bars clubs diskotheken
kneipen und ähnliche einrichtungen
theater- opern- konzert- häuser museen
und ähnliche einrichtungen messen
ausstellungen kinos freizeit und
tierparks und anbieter von
freizeitaktivitäten sowohl innen als
auch außen spezialmärkte spielhallen
spielbanken wettannahmestellen und
ähnliche einrichtungen
prostitutionsstätten modelle und
ähnliche einrichtungen der sportbetrieb
auf und in allen öffentlichen und
privaten sportanlagen schwimmen und
spaßbädern fitnessstudios und ähnlichen
eindruck einrichtungen alle weiteren
nicht an anderer stelle in diesem papier
genannten verkaufstellen des
einzelhandels insbesondere auch outlet
center und spielplätze das sind also die
dinge die geschlossen werden
drittens zu verbieten sind
zusammenkünfte in vereinen und sonstigen
sport und freizeiteinrichtungen sowie
die wahrnehmung von angebotenen
volkshochschulen musikschulen und
sonstigen öffentlichen und privaten
bildungseinrichtungen im
außerschulischen bereich sowie reisebus
reisen zusätzlich zusammenkünfte in
kirchen moscheen synagogen und die
zusammenkünfte anderer
glaubensgemeinschaften und viertens zu
erlassen sind besuchsregelung für
krankenhäuser vorsorge und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen pflegeheime
und besondere wohnformen im sinne des
sozialgesetzbuchs 14 sowie ähnliche
einrichtungen um den besuch zu
beschränken
zum beispiel besuch einmal am tag für
eine stunde allerdings nicht von kindern
unter 16 jahren und vor allen dingen
nicht von besuchern mit
atemwegsinfektionen in den vorgenannten
einrichtungen sowie in universitäten
schulen und kindergärten soweit ihren
betrieb nicht gänzlich eingestellt wird
ein generelles betretungsverbot für
personen die sich in den letzten 14
tagen in risikogebieten im ausland oder
besonders betroffene regionen im inland
nach rk ii klassifizierung aufgehalten
haben auflagen für menschen restaurants
speisegaststätten und hotels das risiko
einer verbreiterung des corona virus zu
minimieren etwa durch abstandsregelung
für die tische reglementierung der
besucherzahl hygienemaßnahmen und
hygiene hinweise regelungen das
übernachtungsangebote im inland nur zur
notwendigen und ausdrücklich nicht zu
touristischen zwecken genutzt werden
können
das beinhaltet und bringt mit sich auch
dass es keine urlaubsreisen ins in- und
auch keine ins ausland geben soll
regelungen dass restaurants und
speisegaststätten generell frühestens ab
6 uhr morgens geöffnet sind und
spätestens ab 18 uhr zu schließen sind
wir haben diese beschlüsse nach
intensiven abstimmung und
beratungen gefasst und sie verändern
natürlich für eine bestimmte zeit
unseren alltag immer mit dem ziel
kontakte zu minimieren dinge zu
verlangsamen und kontakte zu vermeiden
wir wissen dass unsere politik nur
wirksam sein kann wenn wir das zwischen
bund und ländern also zwischen allen
ebenen unseres landes gut abstimmen und
mit gleicher entschlossenheit vorgehen
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass diese
übereinkunft mit den ländern heute in
einer so konstruktiven atmosphäre
gefunden werden könnte
ich habe eben auch die
fraktionsvorsitzenden der im deutschen
bundestag vertretenen fraktionen über
die maßnahmen unterrichten und
zusätzlich gab es heute noch
internationale aktivitäten hörte früher
eine video-konferenz mit der
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen und dem ratspräsidenten charme
michelle dem französischen präsidenten
emanuel makro und mir
wir haben darin auch eine morgige video
konferenz der staats und regierungschefs
vorbereitet und haben über die frage
gesprochen die die binnengrenzen
kontrollen besser koordiniert werden
können deutschland und frankreich waren
hier eine abstimmung aber an vielen
stellen ist das nicht abgestimmt erfolgt
und die eu kommission hat heute auch
einreiseverbot erlassen schon für
einreisen von bürgerinnen und bürgern
aus ländern die nicht der eu nicht dem
öfter bereich und nicht großbritannien
angehören
auch für 30 tage so analog zu dem was
wir zum beispiel gegenüber der
europäischen union auch von den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
anderen ländern schon gesehen haben
wir haben heute nachmittag dort wurde
das auch verkündet bereits eine g7
videokonferenz- gehabt mit den staats
und regierungschefs der g 7 länder dort
hat die kommissionspräsidentin dies auch
deutlich gemacht diese maßnahmen des
reise bands also dass einreiseverbots
für 30 tage müssen von den
nationalstaaten den mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union
umgesetzt werden das werden wir tun aber
wir haben auch über die aktivitäten von
g7 gesprochen und haben uns geeinigt
dass wir koordiniert und im engen
austausch vorgehen wollen dass wir die
wichtige rolle der
weltgesundheitsorganisation noch einmal
unterstrichen haben werden ein
bekenntnis zum zur wichtigkeit des
globalen handels abgegeben und wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir in diesem
austausch auch weiter sehr intensiv
bleiben werden nicht nur die staats und
regierungschefs sondern auch die
gesundheitsminister und auch die
minister im bereich von finanzen und
wirtschaft herzlichen dank
frau bundeskanzlerin das sind
gravierende einschnitte die heute von
bund und ländern beschlossen worden sind
wie lange kann eine freiheitliche
gesellschaft und politik so was durch
halten und sie haben es gesagt auch
spielplätze sollen geschlossen werden
wie will man so etwas umsetzen das wird
ja sehr schwierig wenn sie hierher
fahren
überall sind die spielplätze voll danke
ja ist die umsetzung obliegt dann
natürlich den ländern und kommunen und
ich glaube schon dass man das auch
umsetzen kann und natürlich wird es
kontrollen geben und es wird vor allen
dingen auch immer noch wieder appelliert
werden neben den kontrollen das muss
sein das ist dann ordnungsrecht aber es
muss und ich hoffe auch dass es auch ein
gewisses ansehen der menschen gibt denn
es hat ja keinen sinn eine schule und
einen schulplatz zu schließen um
anschließend die gleiche versammlung von
schülerinnen und schülern vielleicht auf
dem spielplatz zu haben oder eine kita
zu schließen
das heißt wir versuchen so zu sagen
diese engen kontakt bereiche zu
vermeiden und sie ist dann eben durch
möglichst klare aussagen und ich sage
nochmal wir kommen desto schneller durch
diese phase hindurch je mehr sich jeder
einzelne an diese auflagen und an diese
regelungen hält und ich glaube wir
wollen alle möglichst schnell hindurch
kommen aber ich sag ihnen auch ganz
offen dass der maßstab nicht
das ist was wir glauben was wir jetzt
machen wollen sondern der maßstab ist
was uns die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sagen zu dem thema und
vor allen dingen sind ist die zahl der
fälle auch der maßstab die sich neu
infizieren denn es wird einen
prozentsatz von schweren
krankheitsverläufen geben und diese
schweren krankheitsverläufe muss unser
gesundheitssystem auch behandeln können
dass es unser wunsch daran arbeiten wir
frau bundeskanzlerin die maßnahmen
werden die auch auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaft haben wird ist
rettungsschirme für banken unternehmen
und andere eu länder brauchen also wir
haben ja umfangreiche schutzmaßnahmen
gehört die ja bundeswirtschafts in der
bundesfinanzminister verkündet haben
das ist ein deutlicher schirm für kleine
mittelständische und alle anderen
unternehmen
der bundesfinanzminister auch der
bundeswirtschaftsminister am gesagt wir
werden das tun was nötig ist das werden
auf der einen seite liquiditätshilfen
seien aber sicherlich auch dann in der
folge härtefallfonds und wir sind jetzt
ja noch in der phase in der wir
sozusagen diese dinge ausformulieren
und trotzdem sind wir dazu bereit weil
es etwas ist was ja einmalig ist und was
wir bisher in 70 jahren bundesrepublik
oder über 70 jahren noch nicht tun
mussten aber jetzt tun müssen
frau bundeskanzlerin in der finanzkrise
hat diese krise dazu geführt dass man im
g20 rahmen sehr viel enger
zusammengearbeitet hat also es gab hier
ein impuls für eine globale
zusammenarbeit
glauben sie dass das jetzt auch
geschieht wenn nicht warum nicht sie
haben jetzt g7 eigentlich mehr am rande
erwähnt und es gibt eine warnung auch
des bundespräsidenten dass europa
auseinanderfallen könnte in dieser krise
grenzschließung nicht abgestimmte schein
ein zeichen dafür zu sein
glauben sie dass wir überhaupt wieder
zurückkommen zum
pass freien schengen raum das hoffe ich
aber es hat sich schon gezeigt dass die
koordination nicht überall so
funktioniert wie man sich das gewünscht
hätte und wir haben das ist das erste
mal ja sicher gestellt dass der freie
verkehr der waren und güter sicher
gestellt ist wir haben zum 2 für uns für
das deutsche handeln auch sichergestellt
dass die pendler die berufstätigen und
die dienstleister im grenzgebiet auch an
ihrer arbeitsstätte kommen und wir
werden trotzdem sicherlich darüber
weiter sprechen müssen im europäischen
rahmen
aber aus unserer perspektive sind das
befristete maßnahmen die dazu dienen
jetzt einmal die infektionsgefahren zu
verringern
genauso wie wir zum beispiel ja auch
sagen wer aus vom rk ii besonders
definierten regionen kommt auch in
deutschland soll zum beispiel zwei
wochen in quarantäne gehen als es sind
wirklich vorbeugende maßnahmen aber wir
werden daran weiterarbeiten ein bisschen
g20 wir haben heute unter den g7 staats
und regierungschefs gesagt dass wir mit
saudi arabien kontakt aufnehmen um auch
g20 noch einmal eine gemeinsame
stellungnahme hin zu bekommen das ist
halte ich auch für sehr wichtig denn in
der tat ist in der bankenkrise damals
das g20-format ja überhaupt auf der
staats und regierungschefs ebene erst
entstanden
es gab ja das erste treffen im angesicht
der bankenkrise und es gibt viele gute
gründe auch im zusammenhang mit g20 hier
auf ein koordiniertes vorgehen zu achten
frau bundeskanzlerin was heißt denn für
sie konkret zusammenkünfte in kirchen
moscheen synagogen heißt dass das sind
gottesdienste oder sind zusammenkünfte
auch nach anzahl von gläubigen die sich
zum gebet treffen die vielleicht eine
kirche besuchen
naja sind schon abgesprochene
vereinbarte termine an denen mehrere
menschen zusammen kommen also zum
beispiel gottesdienste
aber bundeskanzlerin haben sie heute in
dem gespräch auf g7 ebene auch gegenüber
dem us-präsidenten möglicherweise ihre
verärgerung kundgetan über die etwas
überraschend kommenden
reisebeschränkungen die es gegeben hat
gegenüber europa und jetzt auch am ende
diese am wochenende diese nachrichten
über chur weg also diese deutsche
biotech-unternehmen das ja angeblich vom
us präsidenten gekauft werden sollte
eine für einen bestimmten betrag um nur
für amerika maxime zu produzieren also
letzteres hat heute keine rolle gespielt
zumal das thema ja auch gelöst ist wie
wir am wochenende ja sagen konnten
die bundesregierung hatte sich da ja
sehr frühzeitig darum gekümmert herab
und auch die chef des betriebes koubek
hat ja seine einschätzung jetzt auch
öffentlich gemacht was die
reisebeschränkungen anbelangt so hat ja
die europäische union heute genau
ähnliche erlassen insofern war das jetzt
ein thema das alle betrifft auch kanada
wird wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe solche maßnahmen erlassen in
richtung der eu und insofern war das
jetzt auch kein kontroverses thema
frau bundeskanzlerin
mich würde interessieren ob heute
vormittag im kreis der eu oder auch
heute nachmittag im kreis der g7 über
die lage der flüchtlinge gesprochen
worden ist also einmal die vielen aus
syrien egal ob sie in türkischen lagern
oder in idlib oder sonstwo sind und auch
über andere menschen die überhaupt keine
gesundheitsversorgung haben in dieser
situation und ob es möglichkeiten gibt
dort hilfen zu verstärken über die un
institutionen oder anders
nein ich denke das könnte morgen in der
haltung der europäischen staats und
regierungschefs eine rolle spielen
gerade die situation in griechenland
aber auch in lebt das hat heute in dem
g7 treffen keine rolle gespielt das war
eher darauf ausgerichtet die
auswirkungen auf die weltwirtschaft und
die frage des koordinierten handels in
den wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen aber von
den schutzmaßnahmen auszuleuchten
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
[Musik]